okay so
i am very excited to share that monaco
my jenkins
is
a girl
yep it's a girl for genie mai and jeezy
it feels relieving to tell you guys
because i've been waiting to tell you
guys too jeannie made the big reveal on
wednesday's episode of the reel and her
co-host lonnie love adrian houghton and
garcelle bouvet have the best reactions
[Applause]
[Music]
i understand the proud mama also shares
why she's happy to be a girl mom we
talked about bonding with the girl and
like the choices of fashion for a girl
and all the things that we love being a
woman so i get it there's just so many
reasons why
raising a little girl is such an honor
to me and i would have been happy with
anything but to have monaco i i can't
tell you i feel chosen i'm it's
emotional and genie's gut feeling about
having a girl was right do you think
it's a boy or do you think it's a girl i
will tell you jeezy straight up thinks
it's a boy he thinks boy okay i am still
open for debate because the emotions i
know this is crazy but expecting moms
you'll get what i'm saying you feel your
baby's personality and this is really
very emotional like the things like the
feels and the sensitivity i'm like where
are the men out here that are like that
i haven't seen one yet so unless i made
one dope but like until then i don't
know you think it's a girl he thinks
it's a boy i love her there's been lots
of surprises coming from the jenkins
lately just last week the talk show host
revealed her firstborn's name while
giving fans a tour of her nursery
so this picture was taken in monaco
france which is why this nursery is
themed
after baby j's name
monaco that's really the theme of the
nursery is what monaco is about family
moments traveling discussions
important
key points in my life and jeezy's life
that brought monaco here jeannie also
shared the meaning behind the moniker
it's special because it's the first
place that jay and i traveled to when we
were dating
and it's the first place that we ever
established what was going on with us on
january 11th the real co-host announced
the exciting news of baby monaco's
arrival alongside a sweet snap of a baby
blanket love can do anything to change
your life oh i love it so much and now
jeannie is showing fans what motherhood
is really like posting this candid photo
of herself showing an unfiltered look at
her postpartum body in the caption she
writes quote while being a new mom is
the most exhilarating moment i have ever
experienced in my life nothing prepared
me for postpartum nothing the fourth
trimester has been the hardest trimester
yet but i'm a happy healing mom over
here i can't explain to you how many
visions jumped into my head this moment
i put that little girl into
my hands i thought about my relationship
with mama my that already i can't wait
to have that bond with monaco
[Music]